in conversations I've had with
Lancashire police and with
superintendent Sally Riley who has been
leading this investigation there are
suggestions that if their theory is true
and that is their main hypothesis that
45 year old mum of two Nicola bully fell
into the river wire if that is true then
it is very potential that she could have
flown that could have gone down this
River and out through to the coast now
there has been extensive searching of
the river wire there's around a 15
kilometer path of um of water that they
need to search From the Bench where her
phone was found where her dog Willow was
and the lead for the dog as well all the
way down to the mouth of the river wire
which goes out into morecon Bay now
about an hour or so ago Sky News
actually witnessed a couple of police
codes heading out off the coast into the
sea before returning back onto the river
wire and heading Upstream we can see
some footage filmed by my producer
Darren little earlier today where we saw
two boats on either side of the river
they were specialist police teams
actually searching for either Nicola
bully herself or any evidence relating
to her disappearance we're actually
right now based around halfway between
the bench where she was last seen and
where that phone was left unlocked
to the coast as well so we're about
halfway down the river wire right now
and what is quite interesting is the
first time that we've actually seen this
Jane is that this River as we know it is
a very tidal River so the tide comes in
and goes out and the river is Flowing
quite rapidly actually probably the
quickest we've seen it so what police
are saying is that this investigation
this whole search operation is
incredibly complex because of the nature
of this River the tide goes in and out
quite rapidly and so whatever is on the
bed of the river wire what is whatever
is floating on the surface of it will be
moving with the tide of this River as
well it's why now Lancashire police have
said that they need to focus their
operation their search and investigation
actually towards the mouth of the river
to ensure that there is nothing that's
gone through the coast and into the sea
so it is a very big part of the the
river wire that they are searching it
will take a lot of resource a lot of
time but we now can confirm that there
is police searches going on off from the
mouth of the river wire on the coast and
into the Irish sea around morecon Bay
and police will be searching here for
some time until they find anything
relating to her disappearance okay and
Zane just as Lindsay has been talking to
us the police have confirmed that and
they've also released a statement saying
that they've had to uh they can confirm
that a dispersal order was issued around
8 40 yesterday evening this is because
people have been filming on social media
close to some of the properties in St
Michael's the police are saying that for
the next 48 hours they got the power to
disperse anyone committing antisocial
Behavior a number of people have been
warned about their behavior there the
police say they hope it'll give people
some reassurance they'll not tolerate
criminality including trespass and
criminal damage also the police saying
that they're aware of a number of
grossly offensive comments being made on
social media and elsewhere they're
looking into these and they will not
hesitate to take action where
appropriate